and more covid19 vaccines are making
their way through our local hospitals
saint rose dominican hospital umc and
the va hospital up in north las vegas
received doses and began administering
them earlier on today
to frontline healthcare workers
now staff at southern hills hospital
called this
really a historic day after receiving
their first doses
sunrise hospital also receiving the
vaccine and front line workers were
given the shots first
shortly after a round of applause
mountain view
hospital also administered its first
covit 19 vaccine a bit earlier on today
the recipient was dr clarence dunn again
dr donegan is the chairman of the
emergency services department who
shared his experience uh they're
supposed to be 15 minutes of monitoring
but i don't have any symptoms yet it was
i didn't even feel a shot it was such a
tiny little needle i think this is going
to be the key for us to you know get rid
of masks hopefully and quarantine and
lock down so
you know living in vegas obviously we
need this more than more than any
economy in the us we need to reopen it
the shot was administered by vice
president of risk
management that is harsha dave